vlog this is a keynote I gave my second
keynote I gave two at complex con and
this one had a lot of juice to it a lot
of young entrepreneurship the framework
of how I see the game being played right
now and I hope you really enjoy it and
I'll talk to you soon thank you thank
you
thank you guys appreciate you
how's everybody good
Sofer didn't make it this morning so we
switched it to this afternoon
now Ferg's not making it again so he
asked me to apologize on his behalf you
know how rappers do so what I really
want to do the mic is set up here I'm
gonna rant a little bit but for a lot of
you I know that a lot of you know my two
cents my spiel
I know bunchy came through the booth so
I wanna thank you so much for that I
appreciate you support in case Wes and I
but the mics there I highly recommend
I'm probably gonna go into it like 10 or
15 minutes if you've got questions this
is kind of the opportunity so feel free
to start lining up over there my man
it's not wasting time so cool let me let
me set up a little bit of a framework
before we get into the QA talk about a
little bit what I want to talk about
first of all it's super amazing to be
here because just the vibe of this event
is a lot of fun for me because as some
of you know I grew up a baseball card
kid right and as soon as I walk down to
the convention I was like oh [ __ ] I know
this flavor this was baseball cards in
1989 like just the the level of
entrepreneurship that I saw downstairs
like people literally like wanting to
fight over their position in line
because they knew they had to get a
better one to flip their [ __ ] I respect
that [ __ ] I know people are frowning on
the fighting I recommend it
people trying to eat you know like so
that was amazing and just the level of
culture and then more importantly like
you know I'm old so I grew up where
everybody was kind of divided when it
came to hip-hop and culture and
everybody kind of stayed in their own
lanes just watching this generation
bleed into each other white brown yellow
black green like it's just [ __ ]
incredible and I honestly like people
[ __ ] on Millennials all the time I think
some of you know I'm like the reverse I
think the [ __ ] Millennials are the
best like I know nothing but lazy people
that are older so I don't you know maybe
a little entitlement just cuz things
have been good so you don't know the
difference you know how many people
under 30 raise your hand right so for
all of you the big thing that you need
to keep in mind is you haven't been
punched in the [ __ ] mouth yet right
2008 2001 you know mm you know 9/11 you
know the stock market crash the Bear
Stearns [ __ ] like the biggest thing that
you don't know yet is when the whole
economy crashes you go from being an
entrepreneur of a t-shirt company to
working at Bank of America because the
money gets sucked out of the system so
I'm not trying to frown on anything I'm
trying to put everybody in the right
perspective everybody under 30 here
understands it better the places that
people pay attention to which is the
only thing I give a [ __ ] about the way
you guys collaborate with each other and
have love for each other way better than
ever before the only vulnerability that
this room has is lack of blood pouring
out of their mouths and I mean that
because there's so much money in the
system like it feels normal to sell [ __ ]
through Instagram until 20% more of
people don't have money to spend on
stuff and then the [ __ ] gets tight and
so I highly recommend where I'm going
with that is not like Mara where I'm
going with that is get practical a lot
of people are just not practical a lot
of people taking money and instead of
investing it back into their business
buying dumb [ __ ] there was a whole lot
of dumb [ __ ] buying downstairs today
there was there was a bunch of people
that bought [ __ ] to make money that's
good buying [ __ ] there's a lot of people
buying [ __ ] downstairs today to close
the gap on insecurities they have a lot
of people bought [ __ ] because they think
the logo on their hoodie we're on their
kicks is gonna make them feel better but
it's not and it's gonna speed up the
process of you losing not the other way
around so we need more practicality in
the space that's for sure but if you
came to this and clearly you did because
we're here
but I'm talking to people watching if
you came to this you're [ __ ] so much
more ahead of people like I was trying
to tell people downstairs for a lot of
you you've been [ __ ] with this kind
of game whether tip hop or sneakers or
Street or urban you've been [ __ ] with
it probably maybe even your whole life
right or maybe for a little while the
number one thing as and I'm gonna say it
as an outsider even though I [ __ ] with
it and [ __ ] with me the number one
thing that you guys need to understand
is this [ __ ] hasn't even started yet
everything that's happening here is what
its gonna be you think that's what it is
right now cuz that's your reality
because you haven't lived then enough
places tasted enough [ __ ] and been in
enough rooms for example Nikes a big
shot downstairs but why do they spend
90% of their advertising money on dumb
[ __ ] that you don't pay attention to why
did Under Armor go from being in the
game to being completely out of the game
nobody gives a [ __ ] about Under Armour
here
how did that happen in 36 months cuz
they acted like Nike so be real smart
about what's going on be real smart of
what's going on I heard somebody say
Durant [ __ ] under our Rose sitting on
Steph Curry at the [ __ ] apex right
Jordan speith at the apex they got Tom
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Brady right
I get it my man this is this is me
taking it easy man and so and so they
had all that and you know what they
couldn't do the thing that comes natural
to everybody in this room they couldn't
trade culture they put out piece of [ __ ]
sneaker after piece of [ __ ] sneaker they
took for granted where your attention
was and they thought if they're gonna
drop the Steph Curry's they're gonna do
that as a three-minute commercial during
the NBA Finals and you guys were all off
watching the finals it went to
commercial you took out your phone and
you're looking at highlights at that
dunk on Instagram not the [ __ ]
commercial people don't get it you get
it here's what you don't get you [ __ ]
lack patience all these that just came
through my booth all your [ __ ]
questions
they all came down to the same [ __ ] too
many of you talk about being it but
you're not living it you want to be
about patience and hustle it's fun to
say to me it's fun to tweet that you're
a [ __ ] entrepreneur it's a lot harder
to bleed 15 hours a day every day for 15
years one of my best friends in the
world Dustin sing for throwback that man
and I drove back from Mount Ida College
the day we left college we drove back
yapped it up reminisced it was it was
over reminisced got to the parking lot
around three o'clock that day we hugged
it out he went on his way
took a train I walked into the liquor
store as a 22 year old and I talked to
that man 5 to 15 times for next eight
years true [ __ ] worked it was patient
[ __ ] bled grinded for real not now
it's made up my narrative as an
entrepreneur and it's cool I lived it
there's not a lot of people that know it
but he does he knows the truth he knows
in college I went [ __ ] home every
weekend on the Amtrak not Excel I wasn't
fancy back then and [ __ ] went and
worked and I'd come back I left for the
weekends he also knows I didn't go to
class ever
he was also phenomenon videogames he
should be an eSports star but that's
another story for another day
nonetheless the bottom line is the
friends when people ask me questions or
when I talk or things that nature the
difference is I lived it I don't just
talk about it and I get why you don't
want to do it and it comes from
insecurity you're worried you know why
you guys aren't patient because you want
to win already to [ __ ] stick it to
your [ __ ] parents right the reason
you're the reason you're impatient is
less about you wanting to buy certain
[ __ ] though a lot of your [ __ ] up on
that [ __ ] game it's more because
people are telling you you can't you
decide to do your own thing and now
you're on the clock and everybody's
watching and your grandma's telling you
should have stayed in school but you've
got understand it doesn't matter if you
win in the first half it doesn't matter
if you're up 17 going into the fourth
fourth quarter
you've got to win the actual game you
need to be [ __ ] on in your 20s and 30s
so then you could [ __ ] clown on
people in your 40s and tell them I
[ __ ] told you you understand and the
best part is you got a love you got a
love the [ __ ] losses do you not happy
I am right now that they put a see
before decay and my last name and miss
spelt it I'm being dead serious like
like this is going great I love your
admiration the number one thing I'm
excited about right this [ __ ] second
on stage is they misspelled my [ __ ]
name cuz I look at that and I'm like yes
cuz I love losing you know why I gave up
on the Rangers and the Yankees cuz they
want championships you know why I [ __ ]
with the Jets and the Knicks cuz they
suck and that is the fundamental
difference and I promise you my friends
its binary this whole thing your [ __ ]
life is binary it's a 1 or a 0 it is
black or is it white
you are either gaining or you're
declining there is no in-between you're
not kind of passive right now you're not
kind of in the middle
you're either winning or you're losing
right and you've got to understand that
all the things that you want of course
they should be hard do you understand
the audacity do you understand that if
you make $400,000 a year that means
you've entered the top 1% earners in
this country people
talking about millions as like I gotta
make a million as like an entry point
and they don't even understand that 99%
of people in America don't make $400,000
a year we've got the whole game miss
framed everybody's confused let me tell
you what you should focus on hey you
need to do some [ __ ] you like cuz if you
don't you will be outworked by somebody
who loves that thing and they will beat
you mm-hmm that's the problem if you
don't love it
somebody will beat you because they love
it and that means they'll work 18 hours
day because you [ __ ] love it and
you're working 11 cuz you like the money
that comes along with it or eight or
supposed to be working ten but it's
really four and you're bullshitting and
watching YouTube for six and so I am
confused by people's inability to be
humble especially this audience and I'm
stereotyping but let me tell you
something that's pissing me off that is
the great advantage of the collective
culture downstairs I think the reason
I'm patient and I think all the
strengths I have about all the things
I'm preaching right now is cuz when you
don't come for lunch
you already know you don't you already
know who that like you can be happy if
you have a good household you already
know that you don't need a whole lot of
stuff you already know one nice pair of
kicks is enough if you can't afford
another you already know in life you
have two situations
binary and they're both winning formulas
or they're losing formulas and they
start the same way you were born and you
were either born with too much cuz your
parents are rich and they got [ __ ] like
my kids or you're born with too little
the way I was born in a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] house in Belarus and Russia right
that's it you're either born with too
much or too little and both are
strengths and weaknesses your [ __ ]
mindset decides it
I sit in rooms every day and you guys
know I love to sit with kids and jam and
do [ __ ]
almost every day I have a situation
every month I will meet at least one
person that's gonna cry to me that they
don't have anything and it's hard and
they you know they didn't get lucky and
they got nothing and it's hard and then
I will equally have dinner with somebody
else who will tell me that it's hard and
difficult happened today downstairs
because they had too much they're not
hungry because their parents did
everything for them their mom and dad
[ __ ] them up because they gave them
too much which the people that have
nothing a bunch of you just sat I've had
people who have 50 million dollar trust
funds cry to me a dinner that their life
sucks because they've never fought for
anything they never did anything and
they don't have any purpose and they're
lost and they're suicidal which the
people in here that were born with
nothing like [ __ ] you right bunches were
like [ __ ] that right it's cuz you don't
know the alternative everybody's
pointing at everybody else with that
understanding nobody's deploying empathy
nobody's deploying empathy nobody
everybody's worried about what's their
issue without realizing everybody's got
[ __ ] issues my friends let's just get
to the punch line nobody gives a [ __ ]
about your problems nobody gives a [ __ ]
about your problems because either it's
true either either they've got their own
[ __ ] problems right or they're just
focused on some other [ __ ] but they
can't empathize with you and more
importantly if you think that somebody
owes you something cuz you started at a
disadvantage you're a [ __ ] loser you
have to understand that's your advantage
who do you think [ __ ] Rises and wins
have you guys paid attention to what's
actually happening on earth have you
guys paid attention to who actually wins
it's [ __ ] that had nothing that had
motivation to get something we don't
[ __ ] know stories about he had us and
then all of a sudden he made a pic
nobody gives a [ __ ] about that story
there's no glory in that story and guess
what that story doesn't exist a whole
lot you've got a lot of
second-generation
people doing stuff but by the third
generation everybody got so [ __ ] soft
they're even doing nonprofits all the
time or they wasted all the money I just
ask you would you much rather do you
know I used to cry in college cuz my dad
had a liquor store and I was like
nobody's ever gonna give me credit
because they're gonna always think that
I got like I was upset that there was a
little something and he was around he
knows if it's not what everybody wants
it to be when they're [ __ ] coming up
with excuses why I won and they didn't I
won cuz I [ __ ] out worked you I won
because I had enough self-awareness to
understand what I was good at there's a
lot of [ __ ] I wish I was I just figured
out what I was and what I liked and then
I just [ __ ] out worked you and I will
always outwork you because I love the
game more than the stuff you just have
to understand that when you [ __ ] love
it
you can't beat me because I want to do
it every second that I'm breathing and
so I need people to get to that place
the reason I'm doing everything I'm
doing right now
you know that you're paying attention to
is cuz I'm trying to become your excuse
your shield your thing that you can
point to because if you trip and fall
you guys are worried about failing and
I'm trying to get you to point at me and
blame me then it didn't work versus
blaming yourself
so that it gives you the courage to
actually start doing [ __ ] the only way
you're gonna get the thing that's been
running through your mind the only way
you're gonna get on that plane that you
think you want to be on when you were
sitting downstairs eating french fries
with your homie and chopping it up and
saying what we're gonna be in seven
years is if you [ __ ] outwork
everybody figure out what you're good at
bring value to the people you're trying
to sell and just rinse and repeat
forever till the end and so everybody
looks at the people that made it bless
you everybody looks at the people that
made it and none of you looked at how
they got there simple is that everybody
in this room I promise you my superpower
is empathy I I never make it's true
it's because my man I don't think my
employees should work as hard as I do
and a bunch of dumb [ __ ] business
people do if my employees should work as
hard as I do they should have as much
equity as I do how the [ __ ] do you want
somebody to work for as much as you do
when it's yours you [ __ ] audacious
piece of [ __ ] I've empathy I don't know
what's going on if you're not performing
I
it might not be work-related your
grandma might be sick I'm empathetic
that's why I'm a great salesman you know
I can sell you anything cuz I think
about you first I'm not worried about
what it's in for me I'm trying to figure
out what's in it for you and then give
you more than you even expected so it
feel I'm trying to guilt you [ __ ]
into my [ __ ] and that's it and that's
why I [ __ ] put scrutiny on everybody
who's trying to do you know horses and
pre-rolls trying to get you to pay 4000
for this and 10,000 and all that's like
this [ __ ] is simple all the information
is free you don't need any of that other
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] free people are paying
for [ __ ] to make them feel better about
not doing [ __ ] let me say it again watch
this how many of you when you first came
across me don't lie lying is the devil
how many of you when you first came
across me said [ __ ] this guy I hate this
guy raise your hands raise him high you
know why I was suffocating you I was
suffocating your [ __ ] excuses there's
a lot of people who'd much rather much
rather pay somebody to make them feel
good about why they're not doing cuz
there's some so [ __ ] secret process
that's gonna get you on let me give you
the secret once and for all right here
work a lot based on what your mouth is
saying you want to be a millionaire you
need to become a workaholic right you
want to have good work-life balance and
great family and be on the softball team
and raise your kids and make a hundred
thousand that's an amazing let me just
say real quick that's a ridiculous life
making a hundred thousand that's a
ridiculous life you make forty seven
thousand and see your kids and do your
thing and be happy that's great right
but
don't talk [ __ ] talk your reality talk
your truth create a framework that you
can [ __ ] follow because the only
people listening to your excuses or your
[ __ ] are your loser [ __ ] friends
and you've got a reason it's true man
people sit in little circles with four
people everybody gassing each other up
to not do [ __ ] it's true I'm watching up
my man I'm watching all of you I was
downstairs taking selfies sign of shoes
and watching and listening I listen real
[ __ ] careful
I watch you real quick nobody nobody is
putting on marathon sneakers everybody
wants to be a sprinter everybody wants
it tomorrow you know and I get it it
seems like it's real delicious over
there but let me tell you what happens
when you start getting higher and higher
and did he set it right more money more
problems as real right you want to have
a million dollar business that you're
the CEO and the entrepreneur oh let me
tell you what happens you're in your
eating [ __ ] for a living you're a
firefighter I'm about to get off this
stage right now and there's seven things
I gotta fix problems issues so grass is
[ __ ] greener until you live it and so
if you leave with anything let's break
down the core things and then we'll get
into Q&A number one first and foremost
we need to put empathy on a pedestal it
is the [ __ ] treat it you know it's
fun for me I'm all alpha and competitive
and and dude it out the [ __ ] I believe
in is the most emotional crying real
things you know girly as people people
try to tell me it's not girly it's
strength do you know what do you know
what happens when you expect nothing
from nobody when do you know what it
feels like to live a life when you just
give give give and you never ask for
anything in return do you know it feels
like two in every situation think about
how the other person's feeling even if
they're [ __ ] you up right what was it
Bronx Tale or what the guy was like
except the movie where he's like you're
better off it only cost you 20 bucks I
believe in that [ __ ] that [ __ ] scene
was legit that's right like people you
know me people sitting here still
dwelling about some dumb [ __ ] that
happened in 2011
like it's a fact man like people like
semolina is like my money you know my
mom stole 50 bucks for me in two
thousand thirty thirteen I'm like cool
like I'll send you 50 bucks shut the
[ __ ] up like these are the themes I'm
getting like my best friend's not
working as hard as me cool split up and
let's see who wins like everybody's
looked like everybody knows the answers
people just don't want to do [ __ ] this
is just a [ __ ] you know like even as I'm
standing here I'm like [ __ ] why am I
talking about anything else people don't
want to do it people are gonna come up
with a million different reasons why
they can't that's why the next pillar
matters to me the most you know I have
so much energy you know I mean going the
whole time here I'm grateful gratitude
and I've been grateful from the get not
like cuz I got stuff now I was grateful
when I was building my dad's liquor
store for him making thirty one thousand
dollars a year having no social life I
was grateful because I was conditioned
and it was in a place that I was paying
back my parents for putting me on right
I'm grateful every day when I don't when
I wake up and people I care about aren't
sick right like you know like I just
don't get it like why do people start
caring about the [ __ ] that matters when
they get scared like everybody's living
life you know like when you're driving
and the cop lights go on and that your
[ __ ] heart goes but then when they
when the cop drives by you're like goof
you feel real good and then you start
driving with two hands and the speed
limit for about four minutes and then
you get back to being like ridiculous
that's how people live in their lives
right like grandma gets sick or mom has
a cancer scare or they get sick or
something and then they get start caring
about real [ __ ] nobody's giving a [ __ ]
about a supreme backpack when your
health isn't going anywhere and so I
just don't understand why people are
living their lives like that and so
[ __ ] gratitude whatever you got
it's a listen if you could afford $90 or
six or em [ __ ] you paid for this
conference you are so much further along
than the majority of the earth you just
haven't put the right perspective in
place you have not put the right
perspective in place people complaining
downstairs wearing $213 shoes
shut the [ __ ] up like get perspective
the [ __ ] do you think is going on in the
world get out of your [ __ ] bubble
like people talking about being in the
hood and they're like then I started
poking and they're like in lower middle
class right in America with the [ __ ]
Internet do you guys understand that you
have a [ __ ] thing on you that is more
powerful than [ __ ] every media
company had [ __ ] 2530 years ago in
your [ __ ] pocket we could just laugh
about that listen I can go on forever
people are lacking gratitude people are
lacking empathy you know why people like
me cuz I like them first that's it and
so everybody's watching what I'm doing
and this and that and then I'm saying
things and you guys are really helping
you guys like my Puff Daddy dues are
coming in [ __ ] you're feeding me keep
doing it I love it I'm like I was about
to sit down with this knees are like oh
sure I better say something else [ __ ] it
fresh I need a couple more memes before
I sit the [ __ ] down I'm gonna come out a
little more fresh and everybody hears
this and listen some of you been
consuming this for a year or two you
watch those videos on Instagram or
YouTube watch my vlog or this and that
you get listening to podcast you get
hyped you get hyped and you're like
right and then you stop listening and
you walk out into your real life and you
go back to dumb [ __ ] here's why a lot of
that stuff happened early where you grew
up
how are you raised biggest problem is if
your parents they're pessimistic misery
loves company it's hard to break that
it's it's hard to face the fact that
your mom wants you to actually lose she
doesn't realize it you know that right
your mom doesn't want you to lose
it's her framework I watched my grandma
it's true I watched my grandma parent my
dad well I didn't watch a pair of my dad
but I watched a lot of [ __ ] right i
watch what my mom did with me i watch
other people like your mom [ __ ] you up
your dad [ __ ] you up like that's real
but you've got our sin instead of
sitting here and dwelling and blaming
them you're in control of your own [ __ ]
you got one [ __ ] that bad do
something with it and now honestly now
that you have this
guys do you understand why Harvey
Weinstein and Kevin Spacey are getting
called out it's because the Internet is
now the middleman not 5 to 10 media
companies run by 10 old white guys like
you can tell me anything you want about
Trump this or this that or the other
thing you're missing the point
you're missing the point you know Mike
champion can come back real quick
because they do the right [ __ ] for 24
months
you know why everybody wears [ __ ]
Stan Smith's because they put him on
cute girls on Instagram 3 years ago you
know why people drink lacroix [ __ ]
sparkling water because they spent their
money on Instagram you know why Under
Armor isn't winning cuz they didn't I'm
not mad at Under Armour I'm just using
it cuz you just live the last five years
and watch which brands won and which
ones didn't and so like it's funny to me
just watching it you get it you've got
the part that matters you get it you
what you think
Under Armour and Nike wanted adidas and
supreme and all these things to happen
they didn't they just did the wrong [ __ ]
you know why they took their spot for
granted right they just took it for
granted and that made the vulnerability
and now it's over just so everybody
knows just like the Internet this whole
culture fashion Street all that it's
over my case was steel with Barney and
Patrick knows guys that's the preview
not the anomaly every brands about to do
collaborations with things that matter
forever and ever
and that's where the equity is there
yeah there might be a Jordan and a
couple things in sports but in life
there's unlimited opportunities and
everybody's starting to kind of figure
it out and so huge opportunity in this
space huge opportunity and everything
the problem is do you have the next
pillar number three which is do you have
humility
do you have humility I still do you know
what
and EKU here you know check your DM
because I just engaged with two
influencers on our sneaker thing while I
was in the back room one second before I
came out here thank you
because I'm still back there with the
humility of thinking somebody who's got
47 thousand followers on Instagram that
it might do something for in my case
Swiss joint then I'm willing to
personally write it and be like hey you
want to do something and people hear
that got nothing
aren't even started aren't willing to DM
a hundred people a day cuz you're [ __ ]
fancy and you think you're somebody
couldn't guess what you haven't even
started nobody knows who the [ __ ] you
are
I'm confused as [ __ ] by that do you have
humility do you have the community to
put in the [ __ ] work period
everybody's trying to graduate into
someplace my friends the bigger you get
the more you have to work for them I
have 800 bosses not 800 employees I work
for everybody at vaynermedia not the
other way around
you've got to twisted this world that
you think exists doesn't for the people
really out there doing it not playing it
on YouTube you've got to figure out
what's really happening I need to wake
up and you have to put in the [ __ ]
empathy for your audience because you'll
never make a good product never sell
[ __ ] unless you actually worry about
them being happy with it you need to put
in real gratitude that you're even lucky
enough do you understand your
grandparents think about your [ __ ]
grandparents they have no internet they
don't work the job and go to sleep the
fact that you can work your 9:00 to 5:00
to pay off your debt or pay your rent or
take care of what you have to and then
you can take on your phone and [ __ ]
work from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the
morning that's a [ __ ] blessing that's
a [ __ ] opportunity and nobody can
stop you and nobody decides but us it's
[ __ ] crazy so you better start really
[ __ ] and deploying gratitude and
everybody change your [ __ ] mindset
today make this the [ __ ] talk that
changes your mindset stop [ __ ]
bitching nobody's listening nobody gives
a [ __ ] stop expecting [ __ ] and go
[ __ ] take yours by doing the last
part which is having number three the
[ __ ] humility to put in the [ __ ]
work because if you don't somebody with
real [ __ ] chops is going to deploy it
and take yours understood cool
[Applause]
now now that you've got your mind right
it's about one thing
understand where the attention is and
make [ __ ] for it everything I've been
kind of nuanced that over there about
the underarmor and champion thing is if
you would have told anybody in business
24 months ago that at complex con were
thousands of kids that are cool or
hanging out that more of them would be
wearing champion product then Under
Armor you would have been laughed out
the [ __ ] room that's of two minutes
that's why attention is so important
attention so important because if you're
not smart about it you will lose when
MTV came out they went to the biggest
rock bands in the world and they asked
them to make videos and most of them
said no because they weren't willing to
give away free music and they were
playing stadiums and paid and thirty six
months later nobody gave a [ __ ] about
them and they gave a [ __ ] about Madonna
and Michael Jackson and Rod Stewart and
Duran Duran and whoever made [ __ ] for it
are MTV sits in this place are MTV comes
across in four or five platforms
Instagram and snapchat right Instagram
and snapchat or MTV and B et you
understand
except it's not 1992 anymore right and
so what you are trying to do every day
has become the TRL right you're trying
to become the show and every one of you
can do it and it doesn't cost you any
money the problem is most of you are
losing because you're fronting on your
content because you're not willing to be
authentic because you think you got to
play a part and the ironic thing is all
the magic is in the [ __ ] that is corny
it just is all because you all look the
same
if you're all playing up to the same
standards of what's cool and what's good
and what's good content you end up all
looking the same a hundred percent my
man do you I mean I now have declared
every single human on earth ridiculously
hot because everybody's figured out
angles and lighting and filters and I go
on on [ __ ] Instagram I'm like [ __ ]
everyone's hot like how many like how
are you a point of differentiation if
you know how to kick up your heel and
kick your ass out and that's all you see
for seventy four people in a row in your
feed I don't know your [ __ ] name
right and every dude's doing the same
dumb [ __ ] like taking off their foot
like it's the same [ __ ] whatever it is
whatever it is all the [ __ ] that got me
to where I was was I never gave a [ __ ]
about you I was never gonna pander to
what you decided to that moment was cool
I was gonna live my life and then I got
lucky and it stumbled into
entrepreneurship getting a little cooler
everything that's gonna make your [ __ ]
pop is in the stuff that your parents
and your sister knows about you but not
even your best friend the corny [ __ ] in
your stomach is the magic you just need
to share it with the world please think
about that because everything else
becomes noise but your real personality
your nuance that's the only currency you
can trade on cuz that's the only thing
not replicatable got it like the video I
posted just now right now that's doing
super well about like [ __ ] up on purpose
you guys see this in it my voice got so
high you saw that how many people saw
that like everybody in the comments like
yo [ __ ] this Mickey Mouse puts a [ __ ]
and I read it and I click on it and the
guys living at home with 106 followers
and I reply to him like that Mickey
Mouse [ __ ] is why this one the nuance be
you be [ __ ] you cuz it's the only shot
you got at beating somebody else and and
I'm very proud of this space this space
culture Street hip-hop was a space when
I was a kid that rappers made up their
origin story because if they grew up in
a middle-class family the market
wouldn't accept them people made up
their [ __ ] like made you know they once
visited their uncle in Compton and I go
I'm from Compton I'm so proud of this
space that now we accept regardless of
the angle skin tone it's my it's
incredible what you guys have done with
it so you can't be scared of anything
just be you it's all you got thank you
[Applause]
which what's up Gary hey I just want to
say thank you yo for two guys leaving
this is the best [ __ ] part the Q&A is
where the fire is like gonna be the best
question too and we were in Oslo just
like a few days ago now yes I know my
parents never had this like
communication for millennia so I just
want to say thank you for giving back
when we didn't like my parents never had
this and we have this now it's awesome
so my question is kind of left side I
know but I don't really get to have this
like so entrepreneurs are making it that
have a lot of success let's say you
become a multi-millionaire so I'm using
it for an example okay marriage question
but how do you bet not balance but like
if you make it how effed up is your
family life like balancing it with your
wife it just depends on who you're
[ __ ] with right like it depends on
your partners are like you gotta over
communicate like everybody wants
different [ __ ] like it could be really
[ __ ] up my dad was never home I didn't
see him until I was 15 and dragged into
his liquor store and we have the best
relationship ever and I love him with
all my heart like guys the current state
of political correctness and how you
should parent how you should live what
age you should get married that like
that's all [ __ ] like it's there's
only one story like yours you need to
communicate with the people you give a
[ __ ] about in your inner circle in the
next circle like there's there's people
that are home 9:00 to 5:00 every day
that are [ __ ] up there's people that
spend every day with them with their
spouse every day they both work in the
home office and they're gonna get
divorced in nine minutes cuz it's [ __ ]
up like there's no right size fits all
let me let me tell you how do you how
you really solve what you're trying to
say you guys want to be selfless and be
good and give back be selfish first to
get your [ __ ] to the place where you
need to be when you were in the process
I'm gonna be yes I said hey dude no but
like real quick I'm just using I was
like I'm gonna buy the Jets and you
think I'm gonna slow down and I'm gonna
gear up I'm working harder now than ever
this is the hardest I've ever worked in
my life right now I went to Oslo and
then Copenhagen connected in Moscow got
here right leave for Australia tomorrow
night I'm in Australia [ __ ] tight
Tyler
Tyler [ __ ] me the [ __ ] not you babban
Tyler Schmidt Schmidt really [ __ ] me
up I'm in [ __ ] Australia for 30 hours
for keynotes he gave me two hours of
sleep you know and so like this is like
the hardest I've ever worked then like
it is what it is right like you just do
the best you can bro that's it you just
do the best you [ __ ] can
because it's truth is when you get to
that place in your own head and you're
living in your own head you don't care
what other people think I don't care
what my parents think I don't care what
my spouse thinks I don't kill my kids
think I don't I want it to be awesome
but I gotta start with me over
communicate like hey dude I want to be
big check check oh they [ __ ] up give
me the mic first off give shout-out to
whoever put this complex cuz this is an
amazing event I came from the real
estate wealth Expo and I saw Gary Vee
come in and it was like Brendon Burchard
or Gary Vee and I was like Brendan
Bouchard I wanna see Gary Vee you know
so uh but attitude of gratitude I just
want to thank you for spitting real [ __ ]
that's it you know you the things you're
saying is so right you know what really
matters this is all fun and happy and
everything but what really matters is
tomorrow Monday morning what are you
doing by yourself without the raw raw
all that stuff so as I want to say to
everybody everybody's acting a role here
and you're right the ones that are gonna
win are the same role that was played
out today it's played out tomorrow now
you may have a job but is your head in
that same place are you happy that
you're eating [ __ ] for eleven hours at
your job and you can't wait to pick up
some fast food and then go home and then
grind and have nothing good happen and
then start again Tuesday I mean it like
like do you love like the grind do you
love the negativity do you have that
patience do you like when you lose 100
followers a day instead of gaining a
thousand do you like it I do I do I like
it I think it's part of the [ __ ]
process you can't have the riches
without the [ __ ] so thank you appreciate
you man you got a man and I want to say
one more thing on that the reason I spit
real [ __ ] is because I'm so
fish I know I'm gonna be right and after
you're done [ __ ] with a bunch of
[ __ ] artists you're gonna come back
hey guys just an interest of time let's
please keep it up one question and
really quick please thank you all right
hi thank you so much for being here um
so I come from this world I was pretty
entrenched in this about ten years ago
around 2009 when everything had to fill
this [ __ ] I changed my life and I just
moved into another industry and now I
have a startup called super food school
that is about it's an online course that
helps people to just get more plants on
a page regardless of their diet my big
question is I come from this world / -
it was pretty entrenched arts
entertainment this whole business thing
is a big thing for me so my question is
just someone moving from creative to
really moving into business like I just
learned the word scalability like two
years ago listen to Frank Kern even
pagan all of those guys you and just not
wanting to go back to business school
but really trying to just get on this
wave you know plant base and the online
courses almost like it's the wage so
just here's the problem those other guys
you just mentioned I know them both I
got love for them but they're trying to
make you monetize short term they're
talking to you about short term funnels
landing page optimization trying to get
that money and what happens is Frank
Kern gets you to ask your audience for
money too quick when you don't have an
audience yet do you understand yes and
you know what else you know I'm right
you know what I mean you can taste it so
cool they're not wrong in my opinion
other than they want you to monetize too
quick everything's about create the
persona drive the [ __ ] traffic
optimize get emails free ebook but then
you sell them the thing JV this guy's
got a list all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you understand and I know you know it
is what what you like about what they're
saying is it's gonna happen fast and
you're gonna make a buck 30 a year quick
on [ __ ] $12,000 a month recurring
revenue because [ __ ] that bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] do you understand
so instead there's tried-and-true
methods which
run the [ __ ] marathon keep it humble
put out good content it's super okay to
ask to sell something but you got to
believe in it and if you don't believe
in your $439 ebook because it's a
compilation of [ __ ] that they can find
then you don't do it but maybe it's a
buck ten maybe it's 47 maybe it's
something else
but just don't waver for the short term
okay that's all this is good name is
James you Kawa handles that bullet kills
I do my thing so two years I just want
to get this out of the way it's kind of
surreal just speaking to your person
because I've been seeing you for such a
long time but two years I had kind of
rock bottom and I found you on Facebook
on that five minute ran randomly and
it's just like what the [ __ ] and it just
completely changed my mind
happy [ __ ] one hour drives every day
I changed my health as well I took your
advice I lost 30 pounds like everything
you look [ __ ] great thank you so I
took your advice and I've been doing it
but now I'm at that my question is I'm
at that point now where it's um I hit my
limit I'd done everything I can but now
I need people to help me out why um like
you said I had triple down on my
strength
okay I don't want to good I don't want
excited I got it yeah that's good next
up my next part is you trying to find
people to help me out and there's a lot
of people don't want to help me out
but I have this weird issue in my head
where it's like I feel like I need to
repay them but you know a lot of people
are always like don't worry they just
want to help you out by good I have the
same thing like when people come through
on my team work for free work for cheap
I'm like I [ __ ] owe them for life
yeah yeah there's nothing wrong with
that so I know you take the chance yeah
so I know how people come on they might
bring you value then it's easy to do
right by them the other one's even more
interesting you bring somebody on you
know some point of you like you bring
somebody on you know and they suck right
and you still do good by them because
that's your operating system there's
nothing wrong with that but how do you
pick people not pick people because
there's people that are all my teams I
want to help me out so go ahead exceed
but I know a lot of people in my team
are you know
financially in stable and one night and
then I know you say like do internships
do blah blah just kind of given value
for it yep but they don't want that
stuff so find somebody who does and for
those people I try to bring them on and
kind of give them opportunity they're
grateful yep but as HR point of view
like what do you do to kind of repay
them so I do like I'm thinking of like
real quick cuz I see you want to take
you up you got this real quick it's
super simple it's super simple
hear me out me you're overthinking too
much [ __ ] here's what you do you bring
people on yes
and you take the risk that you won't get
enough value back in return but then you
do right by them you ask them what the
[ __ ] they give a [ __ ] about there's
8,000 people my inbox that literally say
they will work for me for free for two
years because they know the babban and
d-roc and and the entire story because
I'm good enough to pay back everybody if
they do right by me take the risk with a
couple people that doesn't cost you
anything so you can afford it and just
play it out instead of overthinking it
in theory just do it a couple times
you're gonna learn from the doing mm-hmm
simples that cool just get more than you
got thank you you're welcome
hi Gary how are you I'm good my name is
my and I came to America in 1975 is a
boat person amazing yep so I decided to
write a book what in your opinion would
be the best way to market this book
because I'm an unknown writer yeah no
one knows who I am
so I would go to Instagram and I would
type in hashtag bully hashtag Vietnam
hashtag everything in your life and I
would look at the most popular people on
that hashtag every hour every day right
and then you would look at them and
somebody put hashtag Vietnam because
that's where your family's from and they
have 7,000 followers and you DM them and
you tell them you want to send them the
book and it would mean the world to you
if they would shout it out you do that a
hundred times a day
you'll probably get one in every
thousand to say yes once you wrap your
head around that you just keep doing it
over and over I'm okay with the
rejection of course you are you were
bullied
and you face racism you're [ __ ] set
you've won it ready I'm being guys I'm
being serious like if I could ever
convince all of you that your
shortcomings and your detriment are your
strengths you would win like if I was
six foot four and ran like a gazelle I'd
play for the Jets instead of owning them
I really need everybody to have that one
sink in cuz it's the most important one
so that's it do that so I own a media
company I just found it about three
months ago I'm very passionate about
what I do I feel like I have a very good
driving like a good product yeah so my
question is how can I get more of that
product in front of the right people how
can I get the right collaborations I
mean obviously I'm here ask yeah but I
mean like for example Graham you DM 100
people a day you ask one and every 500
is gonna say yes actually I guess let me
ask a different question so okay okay
that's cool if you were sorry if you
were in my shoes my man my man that's
what I did everybody thinks I was put on
I built my dad's liquor business for him
I had I was thirty [ __ ] two years old
thirty four years old when I started
vaynermedia and I had no equity in wine
library had nothing
I built my dad's liquor store for him
I'd zero I was 34 years old
and I never made more than $150,000 a
year even though I built a 60 million
dollar business for my dad I had no
money AJ was graduating from school I
had no savings cuz I bought an apartment
from everything I saved and as some of
you know I finally invested in Facebook
and Twitter that launched me but I
finally did that I know money do you
know how vaynermedia started I asked a
bunch of people that are buying wine for
me if they wanted the way they saw Wine
Library grow for their own business and
some dude gave us an $80,000 thing for
of AJ's friends work for free Mike Boyd
Boyd you hear hey Boyd tell these
[ __ ] how we did it
Mike get on the say right tell them
where you slept some Explorer
say it again on purpose because I wanted
to people didn't get paid people didn't
get paid people didn't get paid like
like I what what you know so fun at Boyd
and have Dustin here cuz they know the
truth they don't they know me before
this you think I'm joking you think my
daddy gave me a liquor store
you're [ __ ] confused do you understand
you know what a did bro I [ __ ] asked
you know why I don't give a [ __ ] when
people say no you know what that means
somebody finally says yes and you
[ __ ] start you want collapse ask them
you want to do something with a boogie
you want to do something champion you
want to do something with cristal
[ __ ] ask them sick so actually let me
ask you this let's go ask hi I'm Lila
Hart stand-up comedian living in Los
Angeles originally from Seattle my
question for you is how do you remain so
fearless in your entrepreneurial
endeavors and why does kindness matter
so much to you kindness matters coz my
legacy matters to be way more than
anything else and that's how I live my
life and the way I stay fearless is
there's no alternative I'm not scared of
losing cuz I don't allow any of you to
judge me guys you're only scared to lose
cuz you're worried about what other
people gonna say my losses are my losses
get the [ __ ] out of my system they're my
losses you think I give a [ __ ] what you
think
you think if I lost everything your
comment if I [ __ ] knew it
he was a snake oil salesman he never had
anything you think that would bother me
that she would [ __ ] motivate me cuz
when I rise again like a phoenix I'll
stick it in your [ __ ] mouth
I'm fearless because and listen I know
your story we've interacted a little bit
at that mid summit now here like you've
dealt with way [ __ ] worse than
[ __ ] somebody firing you or your
business failing so you're [ __ ] good
to pop let's come make some noise
Gary bees in the house baby feeling it
he's feeling my respect so real quick
just keep it tight around here so just
to give us some context I met Gary first
time downstairs definitely became the
biggest fanboy of all time
d-roc definitely captured it I was like
yo Gary I love this [ __ ] man you let you
hook me up but 14 months ago launched a
podcast called purpose in the youth ya
bout unfold the stories of passionate
people yes after graduating college
yes need to find that passion yes you've
given me so much value d-roc shout out
to Bob and he's been on the podcast
thank you bro shout out to your entire
team thank you you've given me so much
value and I know for a fact that one day
we'll be in some type of partnership for
this podcast in the meantime yes what
value can I bring to you through my
podcast just keep doing your thing I
need nothing man
you [ __ ] winning is [ __ ] all I
want I'm gonna get mine by myself you go
do you know they're not even it's not
even like a Gary Vee shout out in it I
was healing it [ __ ] Schmitt like cuz
the sneaker released on the 14th I
thought was gonna be like me being there
and I can't doing what I did downstairs
instead he's like you know we're doing
this party and we're gonna invite 150
VIPs and I'm like [ __ ] that sucks like I
don't like stuff I don't want you to do
anything for me you [ __ ] executing on
the thesis the [ __ ] that I'm trying to
penetrate people's skulls and hearts in
here with you doing that [ __ ] pays me
back 10x do it all
[Applause]
you know how you doing a marquis trilled
i have 8 million followers on all social
media platforms hello
so basically in 2016 you email me say
come we don't get to that all right but
my question is since you're an investor
and you invested in so many companies
like Twitter and snapchat and Facebook
are you invested into blockchain and
Bitcoin so I bought Bitcoin in 2014 so
just I just need
I just need all of you to eat that for a
minute okay I love showing my coin base
to people in like [ __ ] I put in 25k so
geez listen I
I think blockchain is way bigger than
people realize like people are [ __ ]
with it like on a Bitcoin level then let
people a little smarter on the etherium
level but when you understand what the
blockchain is my big thing with the
blockchain is it can it can literally
overthrow America and China and Russia
it's that powerful it's a platform of
trust and we can do [ __ ] with each other
and everybody else is out it's so heady
man I haven't like I understand it
theoretically I haven't spent a lot of
time in it right but I've been spending
more lately you know there's a lot of
[ __ ] I SEOs
get-rich-quick [ __ ] that's starting
to happen I need all the dust thank you
I need all the dust to settle a little
bit I'm watching you know my favorite
time is when I'm like the Cobra in the
grass I loved social media like mm six
seven eight cuz I was just like creep
and I was like in there I was watching
it like that time with blockchain right
now that's hey I'm with a are it's a
with voice I'm a little louder because I
was in the grass two years ago with
voice and Alexis scales and podcast but
now I'm out I think it's super
fascinating I think there's a lot of
people that know a lot more than me
which is why I don't spit on it a whole
lot but it's big big like building on
top of it building on top of the theorem
and taking advantages there's real
things the same way you hacked I watched
how you hacked your social you did a
little different we can talk about any
way you want
but I think if you will deploy some of
that hacker culture into blockchain you
might find some real fruitful [ __ ] quick
question about audio yes I teach English
to Italians right we're about starting a
podcast and for them obviously they do a
little more advanced so I give them
transcripts and stuff like that but
what's the best way to deploy like I
know you talked about not monetizing too
early do the whole Frank Kern stuff
right but obviously you gotta make some
money at the same time right
so as far as well you do that I mean
like but real quick before you go
anywhere how much to me to me that's
like I'm doing this more for everybody
I'll get back to you of course you have
to make money my question is how much
like if you want it real real bad and
you can't breathe why can't you at 28
live with four roommates in a [ __ ]
place I thought you told me you wanted
it so bad there's a great Russian saying
it doesn't translate into English I've
never heard as an English an expression
but it basically translate into you
can't put your ass on two toilets right
and that's what everybody's trying to do
here everybody wants it and wants to
build a big business but they also want
the money in the short term to live that
lifestyle so you know we talked four
times already here
my big thing I mean it and I'm excited
we've talked you know my big thing with
you that I'm trying to figure out is a
2728 right hmm like I need you to really
realize that you should just I feel like
you could win based on our four
interactions here no listen I'm being
serious with that that's a negative I'm
trying to make everybody understand that
I've been paying attention for the last
12 hours I just think you're impatient
and I guess I'm trying to balance like I
don't I don't know I don't think it's
crazy I don't need you need almost
nothing you know that right yeah yeah I
just you know you couldn't legitimately
go on a social media campaign and sleep
in people's houses and have no rent
right you know that right yeah you guys
know that right you just don't need that
much money to live but like you got to
make some right you got a slider just
don't just give all free [ __ ] no no
get free [ __ ] and you're good the more
you'll get back at the end the person I
can hold the breath the longest wins
well then you got to have a side job or
something yeah for like ever
yeah ten years anyway yeah okay now
that's exactly what you should do
I brought the 2017 flip challenge to all
the creators because if you're going to
the goodwill and the garage sales and
[ __ ] like that and making four hundred
bucks a week that way
well then day you don't have to sell
[ __ ] [ __ ] courses on your podcast
which makes everybody unsubscribe to
your [ __ ]
levy my podcast what's that we'd be in
my podcast you do 40 episodes and I'll
be on your podcast alright your hand
okay okay hello hello I'm not
comfortable mic so I just start off by
saying that hello nice to meet you Gary
good to meet you Jen spiration my name
is Bobbi Torres I'm from Orlando Florida
question yep am i working the Texas or
so I'm asking you as an investor yeah
what's your thoughts on augmented
reality and virtual reality and the
opportunity I think industry I think our
general I think AR is huge and it's here
and you should look at it with the new
update in the iPhone and the kit
everybody here should understand
augmented reality you're living it
that's why all that [ __ ] that snapchats
doing a little butterfly pops up or you
throw up [ __ ] rainbows it's here it's
here I like it
consumer VR I hate I think it's ten
years away nobody here has spent three
hours in a VR world in the last month
that shit's super far away but when it
gets here that [ __ ] is gonna be big and
I think when everybody realized you know
it's fun to talk to young crowd the fact
that all of you're gonna wear contact
lenses in your life and your brain is
gonna switch from real life to augmented
reality like Santa Claus is sitting here
and having this keynote with me to
virtual reality where you switch into a
world this mixed reality world that
you're gonna all live in you think all
this technology's crazy and fly now you
think like the iPhone X is rad
facial-recognition this is [ __ ]
garbage this shit's garbage to where and
we're going in ten years and so there's
some kid in here who's gonna make 10
million dollars a year selling virtual
[ __ ] sneakers but it's gonna take 15
years I'm working in that space right
now so it's yeah if you're doing it for
b2b
a lot but if you think consumers are
gonna [ __ ] with VR it's gonna take a
much longer time than you think we
started in a consumer space [ __ ] cool
thank you very much you're welcome
she gets the mic how old are you I'm
nine it's so nice to meet you I'm a
rapper and a business owner I come to
events like complex con I come to neck
network because I push myself and create
partnerships with the with the brands do
you think I'm going at it
the wrong way you are definitely not
going about it the wrong way little one
you might be going about it the best
[ __ ] way here are you enjoying it
yeah you love it yeah what do you do
when you grow up well I'm a rapper so I
really I really um I dream about going
on tours yep like everybody here like
they're coming to see you I want them to
be like that to me
I love that listen can I give you can I
give you a real real real good piece of
advice that's gonna be really hard for
you to take but please remember it and
hopefully when we chop up this video
we'll send it to you mm-hmm
the number one thing you have is time
you have something in here that all of
us envy which is an extra 30 years an
extra 20 years an extra 15 years do you
understand yeah you can't get caught up
in the game that most 9 to 11 year old
entrepreneurs are getting caught up in
that I talked to
Oh what you don't see what I'm doing I'm
musically listen to me
that was funny right my life's funny
listen listen to me the thing that a lot
of you know single digit entrepreneurs
again and caught up with is you care too
much about how many subscribers and
followers you got if you promise me this
it will help you so much if you just
make the songs that are in your heart if
you just make the content you want if I
could get you to just never look at how
many followers you have for the next 10
years you will win it's gonna be hard
all your friends are gonna ask how many
you know everybody here cares how many
and they're grown but if you can get to
that place where you don't care about
that one thing it will help you so much
you could never imagine
okay can I tell you something else yeah
if you talk about your real life which
is obviously very different than our
real life based on how you see things in
the world it will be really interesting
[ __ ] yeah that's how my songs are like I
don't tell fake stuff I really I don't
want to tell fake stuff I want to tell
my life story and how I got here
I love it keep getting your thing girl I
love you
hey let's um I want to take a picture
with you that's it guys thank you for so
much for coming off all of Gary's team
please just meet right here and we're
gonna have you guys standing by to go
backstage all of Gary's team just right
here
all the rest of the audience go
thank you guys have a good night yeah
yeah hold on we're gonna get let's you
know what yeah yeah let's do this real
quick
this would really matter a lot to me
this is when we can give some real love
it's real fun Instagram yet what is it
hold on we're [ __ ] old bianka
underscore there you go hon let me let
me
you know what I'll do this is even
better move I'm gonna follow you right
now and then everybody will go to my
account and look at the last person I
followed beyond dia okay that's right
yo you she's got 28 5 let's get her to
50k huh okay thank you guys so much I
have nothing but love for you that's
real cute hope you enjoyed what was your
biggest takeaway other than I have a
shitload of Jets jerseys
you